all right Kevin is with us in Texas hey
Kevin how are you hi Dave I'm wonderful
sir how are you
better than I deserve how can I help so
I'm 24 years old and seven years ago my
mom said got a whole life policy from us
from a family friend for her my dad and
me
yeah and I'm trying to convince them to
at least cancel mine because they have
some debts and these premiums obviously
are gonna be a burden on them the whole
life policies were means 500,000 and she
pays like four thousand a year in
premiums and some of that I don't know
how much is gone into something called a
paid-up Editions writer yeah now the
whole way this thing is set up there's
like mental gymnastics to me I can't
really understand it I can't find it
unbiased explanations on what this rider
is but I was able to contact the agent
and he was telling me a very big
explanation that you know it add one to
the face value and so that even though I
don't get the cash value if I would die
that face value would end up growing by
an exponential amount and therefore it's
worth so need to keep it and I shouldn't
be cancelling it I just think you know
either way I can get a load term
insurance rate so I'm trying to mince my
family to just cancel it don't know if
that's a smart thing to do because I
don't understand how split up the
ditches right here so just wanted to get
some clarity on that
well you're onto something here you
should cancel it and you should get term
insurance and it's no shock that a whole
life agent when you called them said you
should keep the whole life well duh
that's how he gets his Commission's and
so he didn't want you to cancel it he
wants to get a commission so paid up
additions are in what are called mutual
companies mutual companies are owned by
them the the customers okay
and so technically speaking it doesn't
work out this way but technically
speaking when they make a profit they
don't have stockholders the
policyholders are the stockholders you
are a stockholder your mom's a
stockholder and so they pay out
dividends okay
but it's not like dividend
in stock they make it sound like it is
but it's not dividends in stock are when
you want a share of stock in a company
the company makes a profit and they give
you the money okay but if you're the
customer and the company makes a profit
and they give you money whose money are
they giving you yours they overcharged
you in the first place that created the
profit and then they gave you some of
your money and made you act like they
did you a favor okay and so the IRS has
ruled with mutual companies that
dividends in life insurance are not like
dividends they're not taxable because
they're a refund of a deliberate
overcharge
that's what the IRS says okay so that is
your that's what the money is that's the
money that's being used to buy paid up
additions okay now let's listen to the
words additions means you're buying more
insurance additional insurance paid up
on whole life policies is when you are
if you wanted to just buy a whole life
policy and not pay monthly you could
give them a lump sum they would take a
portion of the money you gave them and
put it into a cash value and you would
have given them so much money up front
that you paid them in advance so they
don't charge you any more that's paid up
okay okay so which one paid up additions
are is you gave them so much money you
prepaid for additional insurance using
the dividends that are the refund of a
delivered overcharge there's a lot of
mental gymnastics here but it is
understandable okay
so they charge too much to start with
handed it back to you in the form of
profits called dividends that aren't
really profits they just gave you some
of your money back they use that to buy
additional insurance and give you the
benefit the wonderful benefit of letting
you prepay for your whole life for that
additional insurance paid up additions
bought with dividends that's what this
is okay and so it's a bunch of horse
crap is what it is it's horse crap it's
manure
my parents policy they're also shaped
like this but they're near sixty now so
their term rate I checked it out for
them but their tournaments really high
so they even need insurance do they have
money they bearing a lot of debt they
have over six to eight years of debt
about a hundred thousand because they've
been buying this horse crap their whole
life a burden you know is it wise for
them to just keep theirs to their term
rate is just about the monthly premium
of this whole life
it depends on the level of the it
depends on the level of debt that
they're in and how much money they're
going to need if one of them dies if
they need insurance then you have to
decide what you're going to do to get
the insurance and what's the cheapest
way to do it but for you at 24 years old
you know shovel the manure out of the
bar and cancel this crap it's horrible
and I'm yeah there's about 16 K in the
cash value I'm just planning on selling
to take that you know yes it to clean up
some of their debts and you go buy you a
term policy and get on with your life
young man you have figured this out
you're you're you have good gut
instincts because you can kind of you
can smell horse crap when you when it's
in the room with you and that's what you
were doing you smelled a skunk you just
didn't know what his name was and so I
walked you through the definition of the
terms and then you start to figure out
oh they truck me too much they give it
back to me it's the refund of a
deliberate overcharge I use that to buy
more insurance and I prepay for it well
how could this possibly be good for
anybody but the insurance company that's
what it is